Hello, and welcome back to the complete guide
to spin here at Rawkode Academy.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
the Go SDK.
So if you're a Go developer who wants
to write WebAssembly microservices,
this is the video for you. Let's crack
on.
Alright. So let's take a look at writing
a Spin microservice
with Go.
For each of the SDK walkthroughs,
we're gonna go through five essential tasks.
One,
write in your first endpoint. Fortunately, this is
already done for you with Spin New, but
we'll go through the code and understand how
the development workflow
operates.
We'll then take a look at pulling out
request headers,
the body, and the query parameters,
all very common tasks when working with HTTP.
And then, of course, the more microservices you
have, eventually, one's gonna wanna talk to the
big bad Internet.
Whether that be talking to some remote API
or communicating with other Spin microservices,
you have to know how to make outbound
HTTP request for Spin.
So let's take a look at our first
endpoint.
We can open main.go,
and we will see that we pull in
the Spin HTTP
SDK.
We have an empty main function, which you
don't need to worry about. Everything is gonna
be handled by the spin tool chain,
which under the hood is used in tiny
go to compile your code to a WebAssembly
module.
Then in our edit function, we set up
an HTTP handler.
A handler just takes a request
and expects a response.
To send that response, we have a response
writer.
All the spend SDKs are as idiomatic as
possible to the language and the community that
they cater for.
So in Go, we have writers.
You can see here, we use a writer
to set an h two p header, content
type text plain
before using format f print f to write
to our writer, hello, Birmingham.
Your local build process is spin build, spin
up, and it's usually a good measure to
add follow all so that you can get
the logs from your module.
From here,
let's run curl
local host
3,000,
where we get hello, Birmingham.
Let's take a look at grabbing those HTTP
headers.
So let's go back to our main dot
go.
Before we do any response stuff, we wanna
grab a header.
We'll do something trivial with the value, and
we'll send it back on the response.
So let's set
name to be equal
to r dot
header
dot get,
and we'll request the x name value.
Now there's no error if this key doesn't
exist.
So we're gonna build on our own safety
blanket
and if the name does not exist,
we're gonna set it to world.
And then let's swap the f print f,
the f print line
to be f
print f,
where we'll put in our own new line,
drop in
our interpolation syntax,
and your name.
Next,
let's add a new header.
And this time,
we'll set x name,
and let's do something with the name before
we return it. Let's pull in strings
dot to title case
name.
We're gonna jump back to the terminal,
run spin build
up follow all.
We'll be seeing that quite a lot.
Before running curl http
localhost
three thousand.
Now because we're not providing the x name
header just yet, we should see hello world.
Perfect.
So let's include
our header.
I'm also going to use dash b so
that we can see the headers on the
response.
We'll provide our x name
and a random casing
of David.
We now get the x name header and
a response
with David in uppercase,
and we have hello, David on the body
response.
Working with headers with the Spin Go SDK,
we just call it get function,
pass in a name, we get a value
back, the job is done. Nice and simple.
So let's just crack right on
and grab the h t p body.
So let's do body equals
r
dot get
body.
This returns
an IO read closer
and an error.
So let's make sure
we check
for the error condition.
Now I don't like Copilot suggestion to throw
a panic. So instead, we're gonna call HTTP
error,
where we could pass in our writer
and an error
Let's see internal
server error.
Although, really, I guess, this is a status
batch request
because there's no body.
Let's hover over body and we'll see that
we have an IO read closer.
So let's do body strength equals IO
read all,
and we'll pass in our body.
Now if we take a look at this,
we'll see that it returns
bytes
with an error.
So let's make sure
we're good ghost citizens,
and we continue to check our error messages.
Then we can do body
actual string
where we cast it
like so.
And let's just use it in a response
And don't forget
the interpolation marker.
So let's jump back to the command line
and run spin, build,
up, follow.
And we're going to do curl
and we're gonna pass in a body and
I'll just say,
Rawkode
and we'll send it to local host on
3,000.
And we get hello world because we didn't
provide the x name header. You said,
hi, Rawkode.
So that is how you
get
the body
using the spin SDK.
So let's clean this up a little bit.
Let's just go back to saying hello and
we'll get rid of the f for an
l n.
We'll continue to set text plane, and we'll
delete all of this.
Okay. So let's do query params.
This is gonna be just as easy as
grabbing headers.
In fact, the code is almost identical.
Let's say that our name is equal to
r .url.query
dot get.
And here, we can take the name.
And just like we did with the headers,
we're just gonna propagate it straight back
using the x name
header.
We run spin build up and follow,
and we do a curl.
And we want to see
the response headers.
Local host
3,000
question mark. And because of that, we do
need to quote this,
and we want to do name equals
Rawkode.
So the query helpers with the Go SDK
are super convenient
just like fetching the headers.
We're dropping ours straight back in to HTTP
response header.
And as you can see, x name
is Rawkode.
So that just leaves us with one more
thing.
How do we do outbound HTTP?
Let's take a look.
Let's tidy up the query parameter stuff
and create a new line.
Don't know why I said that so slow.
Next, we're going to use our spend HTTP
SDK,
and you can already see it has a
get function.
From here,
you can call any URL.
This returns
a response or an error.
So
like a good citizen,
we'll do some error check-in.
And as much as Copilot really wants me
to throw a panic and going to ignore
it, And we're going to return a helpful
internal server error error.
Now we could use IO read all on
the response much like we did with the
body, but it's not going to show us
anything new.
We can run spin, build, app, follow all.
You got it. Like so.
We can then run curl on local host
once the compiler is ready.
So if you've seen these other SDK videos,
you'll have seen that it always fails at
this stage, and that's because Spin is secured
by default.
It will only allow you to make outbound
request to domains that you've explicitly allowed.
So let's update our Spin.TOML
with Google.com.
And so to Spin.TOML,
we have the component, the trigger, and the
build. Each component can individually specify
the allowed HTTP host that you're allowed to
communicate with.
Here, we can do google.com
like so.
We can run back and run a spin,
build, up, follow.
And once that's online,
we hit it with the curl
and the HTTP request is made without an
error.
Now if you don't want to be quite
as secure,
you don't need to specify google.com.
You can also set insecure
allow
all.
This will allow you to make outbound requests
to any domain on the Internet.
And that is outbound HTTP requests
with the Go SDK for Vermeion Spin.
Hopefully, you enjoyed this video. If so, you
can let us know in the comments. If
you need help, you can also let us
know in the comments.
We'll be back soon with more Fermion Spin
videos
helping you build WebAssembly microservices.
Until next time. We'll see you later.